[Music]
foreign
ah we've done it we have done it we're
back
um
we're doing another vehicle challenge I
hope you guys are pumped you know we put
so much effort into setting this up for
you guys
um and I really am very excited about it
because we wanted to do something
different we always did like people
people walking characters in the in the
foreground in the spotlight and it's
like man character work is hard let's do
something without characters this time
because it's it's really tough to like
parent the stuff make it look right get
there's a lot of detail work so we're
really excited to be doing a vehicle
challenge
um this time around
it's about time we mix it up so
yeah very very excited for this I hope
you guys are too the prizes are
absolutely insane if you got no one idea
what I'm talking about we're talking
about endless engines that's our sixth
3D Community challenge
um there is an announcement video that
went out an hour ago on my channel if
you guys hadn't seen it definitely check
it out
um in the description of this video we
got starter files for you to get going
we got links to the Discord server
um we actually have limited edition
collectible stickers this time for this
challenge that link is also below they
look super sick
um really really happy with those yeah
you know a lot of work went into this so
you guys know where the links are we're
here today to kind of talk through your
FAQs talk through any questions you got
um brainstormed some some ideas together
and just kind of get like I said get
them brain juice is fun
um because
you know I don't want to get fixated on
one idea I'm gonna do a submission as
well right
um
and
we we want to kind of get through as
many ideas as we can so that we can pick
the very best one and that very best one
will be uh personally it's an individual
thing right it's different per person so
first off I I gotta I see Zeus creates
here in the chat um Naz you're in here
as well
um we have some very familiar faces uh
Steve I think you said this is your
first time you're gonna be able to
participate in one of these you said you
got three months off work you got a kid
but you're gonna go for it I love it
um oh man I got the chat in two spots
here
this is better
so I'm yeah I'm freaking amped for this
guys this is your time to ask
any questions it could be both personal
questions
um as well as questions about the
challenge
I uh
yo what is up everybody Arc board yes
good to see you Mr ants good to see you
Yousef what's going on metatrox yes yes
metatrox even holding it down in those
weekly challenges man
killing it your streak is like
ridiculous guy Collins what's going on
we got Ronan visual uh two of the
moderators we got sodomonte wait is soda
Monte in the building
where's sodomonte
ah he is crunching food hello hello
I that's weird I can't hear you we are
in a Discord chat unmute yourself in
Discord so I can hear you oh wow okay no
yes did you just mentioned me the moment
I put some food in my mouth so I had to
munch
um but yeah like serious seriously guys
shout outs to all the moderators on the
server sotomonte
um who is also producing these streams
he's helping me with these things uh we
got visual of course we got Ronan MDK uh
sipo and bad cop like these guys
have really really helped out with this
getting this challenge up and running so
yeah and of course you know they're in
the Discord server helping you guys with
your questions and stuff
just make sure you read those FAQs
because they will get you the mods will
get you all right read them FAQs then
ask questions but ask all the questions
you want right here right now I'm I'm
gonna answer them all uh let's see
okay uh fled 58 says does the vehicle
have to go side to side in the intro
um like does it need to enter from the
from frame left
and then exit forward is that what
you're saying like yeah you know the The
Prompt is set up to all be the same same
intro same outro
um
oh Jan yes recognize the the bridges
there very nice
all right voltek any tips for someone
participating in one of these challenges
all right yes I do have some tips for
you guys
um
I so I I've made a piece of art for
every single one of these so far
alongside you guys
so this is coming from a you know person
who has also participated in these
challenges
what I can tell you especially if it's
your first time okay
we're we're here right now to answer
your questions and we're here to
brainstorm ideas so I think my first
piece of advice is let's let's
brainstorm as many ideas as we can and
don't be too eager to jump in to your
first idea
um it's very similar to like writing a
movie
um you know or
doing any sort of long-form project you
got to be okay
being with that project for in this case
five weeks okay so if you pick something
that halfway through you're like
that's that's not a good place to be
granted you know some of you have been
there you've navigated through that
but in a perfect world
you really want to spend some time on
your idea
um don't rush into things okay and I
think it's put really nicely in FAQs or
or even the guidelines I think
um don't rush to start and don't
take your take your time starting and
and don't rush finishing either
um so that would be the other the other
thing is is managing your guys's time
and your schedule you need to sit down
once you have your idea
or even before that sit down and and ask
yourself how much time do I
realistically have to to work on this
right yes we have five weeks but
most of us aren't taking
five weeks to work on this seven days a
week eight hours a day we're not most of
us aren't even
doing five days a week eight hours a day
a lot of us have jobs so we're doing
this in our free time so make sure you
remember that okay
you don't have as much time as you think
you do but granted you have enough time
five weeks all right
um I actually added an extra week
to this challenge because yeah you got
to create a car yes you can use assets
right
sa card I mean vehicle and technically
no it does not need an engine
um it could be a Flintstones
you know car for for all it is or a dog
on a skateboard whatever
um
I'm getting I'm getting sidetracked what
was I saying timeline schedule
um yeah
you probably have half the time you
really think you have
um and then come up with an idea that
you can do in half that time right I
made a whole video on this it was the
one that I did for uh infinite Journeys
um it's an art breakdown of like the
race car driver
and I talk about how I just bit off way
more than I can chew and I know I'm
really getting into this
diving deep into this answer but I think
it is very helpful
don't over commit yourself
not like tee yourself up to
to knock something out
um whether however ambitious that means
for you and what whatever that is for
you
um another thing too if you want to just
participate like if this is your first
time
only a small fraction of people
technically win prizes like very very
very small so
don't don't do it for the prizes do it
to learn do it to have fun do it to
interact with the community it's not
just about the prizes it really is about
like having something fun to do in order
to get better at what you love doing
that that's why we're doing this so
you know be nice to yourself treat
yourself well
any other advice let's see um
yeah thanks to all the moderators too
for
for being in here and helping out as
well
um
let's see let's see let's see
um so guys I I'm happy to answer any
questions even if they are in the FAQs
but let's see Jack can the vehicle be
powered by men for example men carrying
cages full of cats
yeah absolutely
why not
like I said it doesn't need an engine
um for it to be a a vehicle right so
you guys can really do some very
creative stuff here
uh H kin says quick question to
participate do you just upload it to
YouTube under endless engines or is this
okay so you're talking about submission
yeah so for submissions
um you know in the past we have
made the submission link public halfway
through the challenge because we don't
want people rushing through and
submitting something that you know we
want you to take the full time and
really put
you know take take care of your render
right you don't have to rush it out
so a submission link will be dropped
um in a few like all over basically if
you're on the Discord you're you can't
miss it
it's going to be in the endless engines
uh categories and those channels there
under announcements
it's also going to be in the mid
uh mid challenge update video that I
post in two weeks here on the 18th I got
the whole schedule for all of this in a
number of places first off
um it's gonna be in like the intro of
this live stream second it is in the
announcement video third I'm gonna put
it in my channel Banner banner and
fourth it's going to be loaded into the
events on the Discord side so you guys
are going to see the whole schedule
um I really wanted to do that this time
around because it feels better to have
you guys in the know than to just
surprise you every time with stuff
um if you have questions for me just do
at Punisher and uh it'll be easier for
me to see guys
Felipe no you cannot do more than one
submission we're limiting it limiting it
to one submission per artist
these are all great questions so far
most of these are covered in the FAQs
um so pull them up pull up the Discord
if you guys aren't on the Discord join
the Discord it's really easy
um it is as a lot of you probably know
it is the home base for these challenges
it's not technically required but all
the all the announcements all the
information everything is on the Discord
in one place along with the community of
all you guys working on your art so
um
it's kind of a no-brainer to hop in on
the Discord and of course under the get
started Channel
um
we have FAQs all right so FAQs it's just
all the stuff that myself and the
moderators
imagine you guys asking us
and questions we had ourselves when we
were coming up with this technical
specifications of this prompt
it's all in there so pull it up
alongside this video here like if you
have questions on the FAQs hit me up
um
let's see
Dark Star digital what is the age limit
for the contest well technically
I don't know I want to say open to
everyone
but we are flying you out if you win so
you'd probably want to come with like a
chaperone if uh
if you were under 18.
I don't know maybe we should have
figured that out a little bit but yeah
definitely
I think we'll cross that bridge when we
get there kind of a thing but yeah don't
don't be don't limit yourself if you're
12 and you want to make some art let's
go that's what we're here for
let's see
Will Clark where should I ask Tech
questions about the starter UE file on
the Discord
um you can ask
I don't know just in the in discussions
probably
you can ask me here too
um
I Merrick you have a question does the
vehicle need to be visible at all point
of the video so obviously the video well
here let me let me show you guys I'm
I'm in the scene right now so basically
right I'll hide these rules
so we're looking at the the starter file
for c4d it's the same for all the all
the project files right most of you guys
are probably in blender so
does it need to be visible the entire
time well obviously it
you know isn't visible when it exits and
it's partially visible when it enters
the point is to have the main focus of
the vehicle in the center of the frame
pretty much as quickly as possible
because we're we're not we're not
looking at an empty road we want to look
at your vehicle we're here to highlight
your vehicles right so the timing of
this
is created to specifically created
so that we're seeing as much of your
vehicle as possible
um
and yeah like of course your vehicle is
going to be doing like let's see some of
this stuff uh
uh you know it's gonna it's gonna come
in and it's gonna be like
and then like kind of like going over
bumps and stuff like yeah it's not
supposed to just be
all boring like this this is just the
the basic version right but yeah
generally Keep It Center framed
um camera Shake
dude that's like
yes yes okay can you add camera Shake
yes but keep it tasteful all right I
don't want to see Nana actually I can't
even do that because my camera's locked
let's see let's try and do something
stupid
um
let's let's use some gorilla cam
oh I have it oh yep yep okay it's all
crazy
jolt intensity over rotation
oh man this is nutty right now hold on
let me go to Advanced
uh it's like
overshoot I think is overshoot here it
is
Focus Zoom Target gorilla cam let's see
make smooth not an adult
jolt we don't want any jolt
well anyway you can see you can imagine
that this camera Shake is
obviously way too much camera Shake
keep it tasteful please
um I don't want to I don't want it to be
like
the Bourne Trilogy Where it's just so
shaky you can't tell what's going on I
think this will be this will benefit
from
um some camera Shake
like pretty much every render I can
imagine every render benefiting from
some from some camera Shake
um
here I'll just do it by hand
let's see
God dang it
[Applause]
ah
well you all know what I'm trying to do
right
um
moving on camera Shake
all right can the human characters have
some story of course story's always
better
where are the guidelines the guidelines
are in the Discord server under the get
started FAQs Channel and it's under that
first post
yeah y'all Read that read that we've got
a link to the Discord server in the
description down below
um
Regan he says can a vehicle exist in the
real world or use pop culture or does it
have to be original
um this is also covered in the FAQs this
is good though this means we did a good
job on the FAQs because these are
legitimate questions
um I don't want to shame anyone for
asking any question I I remember I was
in
chemistry class in high school and um
yeah I got made fun of for asking
questions and I thought in my mind
that's a that's not a dumb question
and then the teacher makes fun of you
for asking a question like what kind of
stuff is that
um
but for the for the moderator's sake
guys that so many of you are asking
questions go easy on them all right read
the FAQs okay then ask your questions
but
um
Regan yes absolutely you can do the
Ronald McDonald vehicle if you want
whatever
um
doesn't doesn't matter it could be
anything
um
let us see you
Mostafa you're looking for a little bit
of uh inspiration here you say I'm new
to the 3D world but I really want to
join this even though I lack many skills
should I try or give myself some more
time to learn dude this is your time to
learn
I don't think I need to say anything
else like this this project is here for
you to learn 3D it's as easy as that so
many people
who want to get into 3D
um
this is the opportunity this is it like
come on we're gonna put all the renders
together you're gonna be included in the
all renders montage
you know like in if your art is sick
enough it'll be in the top 100. so
absolutely this is your time to learn
um I wouldn't see it any other way
like if you get through this and you
make something cool
and but you don't finish it
you know of course you want to try and
finish it and submit but even if you're
just messing around and learning how to
make car stuff like
you've benefited already you're growing
your value through this so please please
please
if you're on the fence this is this is
here for you guys to learn okay
uh uh Frankies can the car jump or Shake
absolutely
what kind of car is just locked into
place like maybe a sports car going a
million miles an hour but like then
you're gonna have camera shake and stuff
and like yeah they're definitely me
personally like what I'm excited about
is making a car system uh a dynamic car
rig in it going over some big bumps and
maybe a little jump or something to
really get the like shocks and
everything going yeah that make it dirty
chunky like have it swerve in a little
bit hit hitting stuff running stuff over
maybe it's in the middle of a car chase
like there's so much cool stuff that you
guys can do with this it can go off a
jump and just like Mario Kart through
the air like yeah there's so much to do
um really this challenge is pretty darn
open all right if if you're like can I
do this
and you really want to do that
I mean the rules are as long as you're
following the rules you're good yeah
how many vehicles are allowed that's
another good question is a lot you can
have as many vehicles as you want as
long as your main vehicle is your main
vehicle
um
you know what I mean like as long as you
have your main subject vehicle
um generally Center frame then you're
going to be set right
but yeah you can have stuff like it
could be in a cop chase you know
[Music]
see let's see
does your complete does your vehicle
need to be completely out of frame for
the opening few frames not necessarily
no
I mean the template literally has
the vehicle halfway entering here
I understand that like if you're doing a
jet the wing is going to be freaking
like way out here or if you're doing
someone on a skateboard they might be
completely out of frame that's not as
important as getting them to the center
at generally the same time that the
template is centered you know what I'm
saying
[Music]
some people are asking if they can use
Houdini if they can use this or that yes
yes you can use any program
um we've tried to put as many templates
as possible
and we will definitely activate with
anyone for example in the future it's
just having time to do everything but
yeah feel free to use any software of
course yeah that's why we have the fbx
in there
um you know we set up the project files
for the programs that we all use amongst
the moderators
um but yeah Unity of course uh the 3ds
Max of course
Houdini of course and
um if we do update the project files and
we add project files we'll let you guys
know in the announcements on the Discord
side of things
um under the endless engines category
right so
the whole point of like you guys going
to the Discord
reading the get started and hitting the
green check mark to get the endless
engines roll means I can type
at endless engines and then all of you
guys who click the green check mark who
got that role to participate
you'll be alerted for all of these
updates and stuff
um like the submission link or you know
anytime a video comes out that has to do
with this challenge that's the whole
point of of that
um let's see let's go back to the
questions rules about sound and
background
um you can this is another one that's in
the FAQs so you can add sound effects
but they probably won't be used in the
uh in the montages just because we're
getting a custom soundtrack from
um from my buddy Casey
uh for the top 100 and then the all
renders is just gonna be like a bunch of
sweet music
it's really difficult to balance all of
your guys's sound design and level it
out and mix it with the music over four
hours worth of
you know of a video so I probably am not
going to use your sound but add sound
for yourself please add it to your reel
you know if you want to add sound have
fun with it but it's not a requirement
can you use free models like from free
3D for example yeah absolutely yeah you
guys can use assets that's cool I
understand that like custom modeling a
vehicle is difficult
um as well as building out an entire
environment for it to drive through I I
get that that's difficult so yeah of
course you guys can you know go to asset
town and just build it from assets or
you can make a custom and make a unique
vehicle for yourself it really just
depends how much time you have
um where your skill level is at
um but yeah of course you guys can use
assets
they're there for a reason
all right I'm scrolling all the way down
let's see what we got
how many people submit usually
so that number
um I always give out that number it
um in every top 100 Montage so if you go
through my channel and you look at the
top 100 montages the render montages
um then you can see the last one we had
I think 3 600 people submit which I
believe
was the most
so far
if I'm getting my numbers right
[Music]
um so that's pretty sweet
we had I think
just under 7 000 people hit the green
check mark so there's more than half
of the people who hit that green check
mark on the Discord server to be like
let's do it
um submitted which is a great freaking
awesome number that's pretty crazy
all right let's see
all right a million you said can you
make the terrain less flat so it goes up
and down and make the camera follow the
car a little bit
um yeah I I I think so as long as you
generally keep the vibe of the template
um in terms of placement and timing then
I I wouldn't say no to that
um keep in mind though is this kind of
like a two-fold thing right so it's like
can I deviate from the prompt
and of course we all are going to do our
unique thing and build out this world
but like does the camera
um
say I don't say the wrong thing here
either
basically
you guys can get creative get unique
with your submission just make sure it
follows the rules all right
um and the FAQs are all set up
for questions that are trying to bend
the rules a little bit and
I think
it is a creative risk that you take
depending on what you want to do you
know like if you want to have the the
vehicle enter from the top it's like
well it's not really set up like that
it's supposed to come in from the left
side
um you know I'm not saying you're gonna
be automatically dq'd if it comes in
from the top but like
you're taking a creative risk
and you need to ask yourself
is that necessary
does it break the montages does it break
the template
because the whole point is that all
these flow together
right
um so just know that you are you you
might have to take some creative risks
some of those might be too far
um just know that you know it's a
competition and you're the artist we're
not going to tell you
how to do your art
um that's kind of where we draw the line
as as moderators on on this whole thing
is uh
you guys are the artists the rules are
in place the FAQs are there it's up to
you to decide we can't tell you if it's
good or not that's up to you
um
I devil 360. uh yes
the weekend has just begun I feel great
that we've launched this challenge it's
been a month and a half in the works
and um last night was probably the
roughest night of the year so far just
because I was up so late
working on you know getting the stickers
up and running
um if you guys are in here for the first
time hearing about these stickers yes we
have collectible limited edition endless
engine stickers the first time you've
ever had challenge swag this time around
so it's actually Linked In the
description below if you guys want to
pick up one yourself
um there's only a thousand after that
that's it no more restocks
um but I had to get that up and running
like make sure that was all set up and
right of course I had to finish this
video
um I had to set up the Stream
finish the FAQs and details like it was
a long night last night
but as far as my weekend I'm I'm great
I'm kind of on the home stretch of
things right now after this we're gonna
go play some kickball
it's gonna be great um then we got
barbecue afterwards
so I'm I'm looking forward to it I'm I'm
on Victory lap right now I'm chilling
the hard work is done
so thanks for checking in
I appreciate you
oh can you make the whole scene slo-mo
at some point I would say yeah as long
as you rule number three keep the sense
of speed and direction
um
but I think that would be sick
uh with a space scene with a spaceship
be acceptable I assume yes but want to
be sure yeah totally man
totally
um I I tried to
make as many demo scenes as possible in
the announcement video
it's also on the Discord server too
but you'll see like
you know I think I have at one point
let's let's open up another one of these
demo scenes
um
we got a submarine
in here
oh wow why is it so chunk I don't know
why it's so chunk
what's going on
you hide
these guys
so weird why am I getting this super low
um
so this just gives you an idea like
also this was before we flipped we were
going back and forth on Direction
um so this is before we flipped it
but this just gives you guys an idea
like
there's a lot you can do there's a lot
you can do with this I think we also
have uh
of course we have a jet
in here
right again before we flipped the
template don't be like oh but we're
going left no
no
um
so yeah you can see how it's like
generally Center framed right
and
you know we're seeing it like kind of
slightly angled out and here's the get
here's another here's another uh example
is the big rig here's a good example oh
this was the thumbnail I I used this to
make the thumbnail
basically the big rig clip if you open
that up let me play for you guys
it's a good example
I should probably add these demos to the
to the starter file
do a little V2 starter file for you guys
but
um the big rigs so you notice
all right we come in it's longer but
what if it was a train right it would
just go off into the background you
would never see the end of it and that's
okay as long as the front of it right
here is like the center right
and the big rig I think never completely
leaves frame we cut like right after
this and if it again if it's a train
it'll be going all the way into the
background right
that's okay that's okay just the
important thing is the timing of its
intro and its outro the sense of speed
and direction that's what's important
um so I thought that was a good one to
highlight for you guys
yeah the thumbnail thumbnail is tough
making YouTube thumbnails geez it's
always the last thing on my plate
and
it takes so much time goodness gracious
it takes so much time to make a good
thumbnail and there's so much pressure
on the thumbnail because it makes or
breaks
someone clicking your video or not
and so it's like I save the most
important element for the very end you
know
um but I think it turned out pretty nice
let me pull it up for you guys
see it in all of it all its Glory
yeah it takes it takes a long time to
do these but
thumbnail techniques man
um I'm always viewing them like who
knows if you guys want this info or not
but
I'm basically always viewing them at a
super small God dang it
all right am I doing this or am I doing
this let's do it right
I view my thumbnails like this when I
make them because it's like this is how
you guys are gonna be seeing them anyway
they're never viewed like this of course
so
things I'm doing like little Edge
highlights to separate this truck from
the background like these little
highlights were never there
but I added them because you couldn't
really tell it was a truck
so I added this even the grill and the
in the windshield as well
um these are just uh Studio Studio
Ghibli
backgrounds that I added in because the
ones that came out of
c4d were rough
um
you know highlight here around the
motorcycle around the character this arm
wasn't up before it was just
you know basically hidden so I was like
let's get the arm up let's try and make
it look more like a person try and
silhouette their shape here with the sky
um this car right yeah of course I'm
trying to do a little edge here it
doesn't look good when you're up close
right
and then I added this here too because
it's like this just looked like a white
Mass before but like oh it needs to have
the same shape as this on the other side
um the background here was confusing
this line I really wanted to see that
line so I made sure to like get it up
against the blues there's a lot of like
it's all just it's like a technique and
composition or an exercise in
composition
but I wanted to split up this render
into like three things because we can
see it's all
different renders come together that's
the whole point so I really wanted to
capture that in the thumbnail
and there's just a lot that goes into it
and I put a lot of pressure on it and I
always save it for the end
but
yeah maybe this year I'll try and work
with someone to help me with some
thumbnails or something because they're
difficult
they're difficult
um they're important that's what it is
all right
can you use an animal as your vehicle
huh
foreign
I guess we never thought about that
maybe if there's someone riding if
there's someone writing it absolutely
absolutely
uh no no question about it if it's just
an animal
or just someone running like if it's
someone on Rollerblades yeah we can you
can do that
if it's just someone running like
I guess
as long as they're taking up the visual
weight and like the sense of speed and
you're following the rules
but it's a vehicle challenge come on
let's let's get down to it it's a
vehicle challenge all right so
you know can a piece of paper be your
vehicle maybe if it's an origami car or
something cool
can the vehicle be floating heck yeah uh
like say it's a sand traveling vehicle
and has some vertical metal fins you
mean like a sand speeder from Star Wars
absolutely hovercraft absolutely of
course
yeah
I could see it like coming in like this
where it's like
okay let me see if I can like get this
guy going
yeah it comes in like this where it's
like
[Music]
right and then it takes off and it like
leaves like yeah like that totally no
reason why why you shouldn't be able to
can the vehicle teleport slash disappear
on a few frames
um
why not I mean if it
if
um like obviously you don't want it to
teleport into place
you kind of want it to come in to lead
in like this but you're talking about
teleport in and out here like let's say
let's say there's a roadblock coming
just a big a big roadblock of some sort
and the vehicle teleports
to to like hop to the other side of the
barrier that would be sick yeah
absolutely and then it like takes off
and maybe teleports out like
and leaves that way I think that yeah
certainly can you do a Transformer as a
subject so it it's starts as a car turns
into a robot and at the end a car again
dude okay Loki
we were talking about that prompt or
like a submission like that
and we were hoping
we were hoping
so yes
but but don't everyone go doing
Transformers now all right that's that's
the thing it's like I mentioned one
thing
I think it was on Alternate realities I
mentioned a plant like some guy carrying
a plant dude there was so many plant
renders
and one of the plant renders I think won
first place too
Max can the camera angle be altered or
changed this isn't this is a good
question a valid question I'd say it's
the number one question
we cover this in the FAQ for sure
so go check that out like I said again
go check out the FAQs
all right
um but
uh uh you let me get it right actually
let me go to the FAQs
and read that one off for you because
because it was it was it was well
answered uh Ronan and a couple of the
other moderators went in there and did a
good job
all right so the question is under the
camera FAQs can I adjust the camera a
bit right
you can change the shutter speed for
motion blur right
um You can change the aperture or the
f-stop for a deeper depth of field for a
blurrier background but you cannot
change the focal length meaning a wide
angle or a zoom you cannot touch that
you can't rotate the camera in any which
direction
of course camera Shake is like a slight
technically you are rotating the camera
but
I think y'all know what I'm you know
what I'm saying um but yeah you can't
rotate the camera or you can't move the
position all right the the angle is
locked that's the only way
that these
um
renders match with each other and blend
into each other okay if someone goes
doing some top down shot like what the
heck is like no
uh disqualified immediately
uh and am I in my mid challenge update
for you guys that comes out on the 18th
of this month I'm gonna go over
what would be uh a proper submission and
what would be disqualified
I'm specifically going to show you what
I'm looking at
that is the difference between y'all
being disqualified and not being
disqualified technically meaning frame
count frame rate
resolution that kind of stuff so we're
going to be on the same page we're going
to get as many people into this all
renders Montage as possible guys
um
do the stickers deliver to Canada you
bet
you bet
absolutely I try to get the shipping
down as low as possible I like custom
input
a bunch of different shipping rates for
all over the world so we're trying to
get you guys the lowest shipping
possible on those stickers
um but yeah boy we got him to Canada get
you a sheet son
sticker sheet comes with 12 stickers
a bunch of different sizes
different colors
different logos for the endless engines
challenge collectible stickers limited
edition stickers
all right
Will Clark you mentioned something like
this earlier if I add
ant lions from Half-Life 2 all right
for example chasing the vehicle will you
run into copyright issues heck no son
Bring it on Bring on the ant lions I'm
ready
Half-Life 2 was one of the best games
ever
um that's covered like you said I
mentioned something like this earlier
you are correct it is in the FAQs can
you use copywritten like IP or existing
IP
would be the technical
question
um yes you can do the Ronald McDonald
Play Place
freaking Ronald McDonald mobile I don't
know doesn't the Hamburglar have a car
or something
can we can you use a dragon for the jet
template if someone's riding it yeah
can you use spaceships as a vehicle yes
guys yes yes yes yes
come on now
sorry did I make you feel bad I didn't
mean to make you feel bad with that one
you guys can do a lot of cool stuff
that's the point
can the camera be stationary then start
moving when the car appears on the scene
nope nope no
keep the sense of movement
don't touch the camera position
rule number three baby keep the sense of
speed and direction keep the sense of
speed and direction
[Music]
foreign
dude thank you for the kind words I'm
glad that uh
that we're doing some cool stuff I'm
glad that this challenge inspires you to
do some cool stuff man that's what's up
Winnie Joe guitar with the Super Chat
shout outs to you hey Clint your chance
of failures absolutely dude
weren't you saved polar bears before or
save the polar bears
maybe I'm getting that mixed up but I
remember you
you always did
a chance of failure is absolute zero
you know if I really think about that
that is very very comforting so thank
you thank you very very much man
appreciate that
display the rules again I got you I got
you I got you
they're on the Discord y'all though get
on that Discord
foreign
can the vehicle change speed in the
animation
yeah
yeah I can change speed
like it's kind of the same thing as
going into slo-mo right
um bouncy cow
no sound will be used in judging all
right so you can do it but we're gonna
turn it off we don't want sound to like
influence
uh you know if like the sound design is
incredible in this incredible render but
then you also have another incredible
render without sound design the one with
sound design
it's probably gonna be cooler
so we turn off all sound design when
judging
all right so you're asking like if you
want to do a spaceship for the jet
template technically
the template is what we're looking at
here there is no jet template there is a
jet example
um
and then you say do we need a different
template no yeah there's only one
template there's only one template the
jet is just an example of how I
did a jet but using this template right
what's the name of the song playing
right now I don't know Soto can you
is that info available
so I don't know the exact song but
they're from
stream beats I believe
um
but I I can't tell you the exact song
because I have them all in the playlist
yeah stream beats pretty crazy like that
someone just makes all that music and
it's like yeah use them for your streams
it's pretty what a service to the world
foreign
ER Peach thank you
thank you very much no message needed
huh just a straight up
straight up a little bit a little bit of
support there I appreciate that
um so ideas there's so many ideas we've
gotten into some ideas answering your
questions if you guys have any more
questions that is why we're here I'm
gonna be here until about
noon my time which is
basically another hour I'll spend
another hour with you guys we'll chill
out together
um
let's get back real quick
to
um the question of any advice
for participating in this challenge if
it's my first time
um so what I usually do once once I have
generated a bunch of ideas I thought of
a bunch of ideas I brainstormed them
I've written them down
um like I love free writing so I'm
actually reading this book right now
it's called the artist's way
and it's by Julie Cameron I believe is
her name and the book is it gets into
it's like a creative workbook
it's a 12-week course
um and it gets into
essentially
unblocking yourself as an artist
right
so one of the things and one of the ways
to do that
recommended in this book is to free
write every morning three pages for
about an hour
and that writing doesn't have to be good
it doesn't have to be bad it doesn't
have to be anything other than you
sitting down and writing those three
pages
for that hour every every morning
um and it basically like
from like I'm I'm doing like the long
answer here and let me see if I can
remember where I'm going
yep got it okay basically
um the idea is that you're setting
yourself up to create the habit of
writing and if you're setting the stage
for
um for ideas when the ideas show up
then and it's not going to be every time
every morning you sit down that's not
the point the idea is to kind of be
ready for the ideas
you'll be writing every morning anyway
and then you get into it right so
what I'd recommend is free right you can
just grab you can do it by hand or you
can do it through a computer just type
to yourself what would be cool like oh I
should do this what if it's a spaceship
what if it's someone riding a horse and
they're like jumping over a castle wall
you know like go crazy and then
highlight the ideas that like actually
could be cool and then Whittle that down
to the idea you want to do take a couple
days to do this you don't have to have
the answer right now on the stream let's
go right
um so that'd be my first piece of advice
that's kind of what we touched on a
little bit earlier
next what I would do is draw out your
scene
um do some thumbnail sketches for it and
see kind of like
give yourself a direction you're giving
yourself a direction to go you're not
just opening your program and you're not
going to start detail modeling
um a big rig right uh you're gonna
try and see if you can do a thumbnail
version of your idea and see if it works
and looks cool
um another way or like the next step
could be making a block out and what you
see here this project file this template
file is a mini blockout this is my block
out of a of a car here let me open up
another one of these scenes here I'll
show you another example of a block out
um
let's open up the motorcycle
scene real quick
again the direction is flipped
disregard
um
here we go this is a blockout
this is like if I were to do a
motorcycle scene going through the city
under tunnels this would be my block out
and I would be like huh maybe I want to
see a little bit more of the skyscrapers
in the background so I'm going to maybe
make the foreground buildings push them
back a little bit or make them smaller
so this is where you get to play with
your composition play with the your
sense of speed uh
you know play with your shapes that kind
of stuff and even your lighting you can
get into your lighting so I think this
scene is lit like uh some dark night
Style
um let's see if I can
render this for you real quick
[Music]
so you play with your lighting as well
right and you block it out you don't go
for the detail right off the bat right
once you have a blocky version of your
scene where it's feeling right the
animation feels good
um your shapes feel nice then you can
start getting into like
breaking down what you need to focus on
to bring your scene to life so like you
could spend forever working on the
details of this Tunnel right but why
would you do that when the point of your
scene
is
the motorcycle that's your focus right
so basically
you could submit this right you could
submit this but
you got five weeks so you're not gonna
do that you wanna bring as much of it to
completion as possible starting with the
most important stuff so I would take
time to build out a schedule for
yourself be like I got to be done with
the V1 by this point I got to be done
with like the detailed version of my
scene at this point I gotta be done with
I have to have it rendered because
rendering takes time
I want it rendered by this point and
then I want to be out and out of like
after effects or Da Vinci by this point
so that I'm ready to submit a week
before the deadline so kind of give
yourself a little schedule build it out
for yourself and that'll give you a
track to
to complete a render without having to
pull your teeth you know or pulling
teeth or uh making it a very painful
process
a lot of you guys have done this before
you guys don't really need that advice
but for those first timers when you're
starting a big bigger project
do it like you would with a drawing
you're gonna you're gonna sketch it out
first
and then you go in for the details all
right so don't don't hop right into the
details
I did I did that
on my infinite Journeys render I made
that video the art breakdown for that
video
um it's the thumbnail with the race car
driver with the helmet
go watch that you you see how rough that
was for me and um
yeah don't don't do don't do what I did
essentially
[Music]
natronic do I have blender tutorials for
this
um
no not this specifically not this
challenge you know there's a million
blender tutorials on YouTube of course
blender Guru if you're trying to learn
how to
you know how to navigate blender his
donut tutorial is probably the staple
right that's the number one
but no there are no tutorials on
specifically here's how you make a car
for this challenge
can I second or two be added to the
animation before the vehicle comes into
the shot
that's going to be an absolute no
um each render needs to be the same
duration exactly 120 frames at 24 frames
per second
for an exact five seconds
um
just the way it is I mean you can do
that for you you can add two seconds of
pre-roll for you if you want it for like
your reel or something
but whatever you submit has to adhere by
the rules
um Mohit raghav yo what's up
um thank you very much for the Super
Chat does the vehicle have to be in
focus at the start
so if you look at my screen you can see
there is there's no vehicle there's
nothing here
but if we go to the next frame oh sorry
sorry
technically this would be the first
frame but still we got nothing so that
so the answer to your question is no it
does not be you need to be visible from
frame one but
pretty quickly it comes in right
the reason I did all those like test
renders and those test scenes is to just
show you that each vehicle
is a little different on the way it
enters and exits right but the timing is
the same the vehicles are landing in the
center at the exact same time that's the
whole point right
so hopefully that helps you out
um as an example this scene
the motorcycle is completely gone by the
by the by the last frame and it's not
even introde until the first frame
um
or technically we start to see a piece
of it in frame
frame one this is what it should look
like and these are these are older files
so these aren't exactly lined up to what
you guys would be seeing but yeah
I think I've made my I've made myself
pretty clear on that uh Jew Viola Grace
thank you for the Super Chat
super kind of you
do I know where to get free assets and
models um cgtrader.com is a good one
of course you got turbo squid
hum 3D I think is one that's just like
all vehicles I think uh visual you know
about that yeah visual got me on that
tip
foreign
[Music]
Casper can you choose any car you'd like
or just like or just this car no I mean
if you watch the announcement video my
the first thing is watch the
announcement video guys
I get into all this stuff all these
questions you're asking but that is why
I'm here is to answer all these
questions
it's open to anything any vehicle you
want any vehicle you want it doesn't
need to have an engine even all right
um
we want you guys to be able to do pretty
much
any vehicle whatever could pass as a
vehicle like I'm down
Daniel where should you submit the work
the the submission link is going to be
announced in two weeks from now all
right during the mid challenge update
it'll be on the Discord server
um so don't worry about submission yet
just focus on your idea
while using a downloaded 3D model have
an impact on the judging well it'll be a
little it'll be difficult to to know
whether you used
an asset or not
um maybe in the
uh
in the submission
page will add a thing for comments or
notes or something and then we can look
at it then but I don't know if it comes
if it comes down to like
and we're judging uh for who wins top
five this only matters for top five okay
guys but if we're looking at top five
and we have two equally amazing renders
but someone hand modeled a custom
vehicle and then someone downloaded a
vehicle then I would say the hand
modeled one would win in my mind but
that only comes down to the top five
I'm not looking at that for even the top
100 it's just does the render look
amazing and does it follow the rules
yeah you're in you know
can the vehicle jump heck yeah the
vehicle can jump
it does not have to be a machine
sore yanch it does not have to be a
machine it does not have to have an
engine
someone could be riding a dragon
if you want
um
Amelie if I'm saying that right that's a
good question does the environment speed
have to be
um uniform throughout all these vendors
like the environment of the plane will
be slower than the environment of car
does it have an impact
um I understand that the speed
or the sense of speed
will change from render to render the
the idea is to maintain the sense of
speed let's say you have a spaceship
floating through space it's moving
faster than anything anyone could ever
render
but it's gonna look Frozen
it's just gonna look like it's sitting
there because there's there's no there's
nothing to help with the sense of speed
right
so in that case have some asteroids
flying by have have it going by some
planets or something
do something
to maintain the sense of speed okay
um
yeah I think that answers the question
right Panda BB what's up thank you for
the Super Chat uh you want to get into
3D rendering always love watching your
videos uh challenge videos
how much should a PC for three 3D
rendering be I don't know
something good for like maybe under a
thousand us
maybe cheaper I don't know
um
I don't know how that like equates to
like currency overseas and whatnot so
the monthly do you have
do you have any insight on like
how much it would cost to get a decent
3D rendering machine
well it really depends I mean if you can
find some good second-hand gaming
computer it could be fairly cheap but of
course the more you spend the more
powerful it will be so it's also how
ready are you to wait more for renders
or is it worth it for you
[Music]
yeah that's that that's that's very fair
I actually made a whole video on
like explaining each part of the
computer
and how it relates to 3D artists
um and what you can look at and rigs to
build and whatnot it's a video called
like PC parts explained it's me like
this
oh just hold on
it's me like this
and there's just like a PC rig next to
me go to my videos scroll down you'll
find it hopefully that'll help you out
um
is there a reference for how fast the
speed should be slash feel yeah the
the the
um the template file
[Music]
probably more
I mean yeah it's like you'll you'll see
in all the different like example scenes
that I did I don't know it's not they
are example scenes
um
you'll see how like the jet feels like
it's moving a little slower than
the big rig
but they're still valid so
the template file is is kind of the
ground Truth for that stuff though
can it be stylized absolutely
that's that's up to the artist
make it look like an anime if you want
I hope to get some Sunset anime Vibes on
this one
can the vehicle be facing the opposite
direction and basically slowing down
instead of speeding up
you exit the frame
no it needs to be moving to the right
it needs to be moving to the right we
can't you can't flip it
how do you open the template file for
file for ue5 all right so for ue5 I'll
just show you I'll show you
um
all right so here's your starter files
project files
we have Unreal Engine okay I'm going to
copy this
projects I'll delete this
actually you know what I'm not because
I've already opened it but oh okay never
mind
we'll do it together I'm going to open
this up
it's going to load some shaders but
it'll be quick
and I'll just show you guys the unreal
side of things
dude I don't know what a tonk is but
whatever rocket propelled tonk sure I
guess I don't know
[Music]
all right so this is what you see when
you open up the unreal file
and you're like okay
where do I find my stuff well uh control
spacebar is going to open up your uh
it's been a minute since I've been in
here
I don't know what the heck is this
content browser
I already forget I'm gonna dock it in
the layout
content I was right yes
um
and you're like okay well what do I see
here we have
this movie pipeline file which will be
very important
this is the level we're in let's go into
this folder let's see what we got here
these are this is this is like the
models the assets
geometries of course animations is what
you want you're going to open up that in
sequencer
now if we play this we don't really have
anything but you need to hop into the
camera once you're hopped into the
camera
either one of these
will be solid and then we can Loop it
should just Loop for us
all right so this is exactly what we
have in c4d but we're inside of
Unreal Engine
sweet
um now when you go to render this
all right we're gonna use the movie
render Q
and I cover all this in all my unreal
tutorials
but we'll open this up and you're going
to look and you're gonna see that the
output resolution is not what we have in
the uh the technical specifications for
export right so
you're like well what the heck basically
you need to load that file
and then boom we're set up 1920 by 8 10.
you're good to go of course you can add
all of your console variables and your
anti-aliasing and whatnot but it'll be
locked at 24fps
frame 1 to 120 and 19 by 810 or 1920x810
so that's what that um
what what this file is this movie
pipeline thing it's just render settings
save file
so hopefully
hopefully that works for you guys
hopefully that's that's pretty
easy to understand for you guys
um
for those of you who use unreal okay
dude that thing rips
wow
sweet
yeah good times
r.screen percentage 5000 yo John Jags
knee what's up Jags
what's up dude yes
so I met Jags at uh
at Camp mograph two years ago
um and
you were just tearing it up out there
man you were filming a bunch of BTS
and they like you were adamant too you
were like no they were like there's no
cameras no technology and you're like
getting all these sweet shots and then
eventually the guys were just like yo
can we just hire you to like make stuff
for us because that was actually really
good I love it
and um Jags also you know he's got uh
tutorials and um kind of Lifestyle
videos for 3D artists so definitely
check them out John Jag's knee
good to see you though man what's up
Good Times Will Clark you've been
watching my UE videos can you post a
list of your console variables haven't
found a formal list in some of my ones
from my site seem to break my scene
all right yeah I I do have those they're
in
the video called how to make Unreal
Engine look like a movie it's the one
with like
the dude bald-headed guy silhouetted
sitting in a club
like this he's chilling in the club
that's the thumbnail you're looking for
um
I might have a playlist for Unreal
Engine videos maybe not but
if you go to that one I think they're
pinned in that video
um if you just
they should be in there they should be
in there but just know that like you
don't need all of those console
variables
I kind of for the lap for my last few
renders out of unreal I've only been
doing like screen percentage to 150.
and that's that's kind of it
um motion blur quality if needed but
as far as all of the ray Trace settings
cranking all that stuff
I I didn't you don't really need it
so basically you want to build it from
the bottom and build up to that list
that I have right
um but I can tell you right now you
don't need all of that you can really
build it from the bottom and see what
you need because it adds render time it
makes it crash all that kind of stuff
what do you mean by vehicle can it be a
horse carriage a spider with Mech legs
that someone's right that someone rides
yes yes yes
a vehicle is just something that you're
on that moves you to another place
whether that's a skateboard
a spider Mech
a dragon
um
a house that's on wheels
house Moving Castle these are all
vehicles guys
[Music]
if we download an asset that has a
license
must we credit the original artist that
made it there kind of is like no place
to do that and we've hadn't done that in
the past
um
yeah there's not really a place to put
that credit you can put it in like your
yeah I just don't know where you would
put that
I don't really have an answer for that
one I apologize
have I ever felt imposter syndrome I've
always felt that my work isn't actually
good enough
um yeah yeah sometimes
mostly
when I'm doing short films
um live action stuff directing stuff
it always feels like
like not professional Kitty not serious
you know if I'm trying to go serious you
trying to you trying to direct something
serious and then it's just like this is
cringe
yeah you don't want that
I definitely don't want that so I I do
feel that with pretty much
every short film I've ever done
um
but honestly these vendor challenges
not gonna lie they're sick they're
freaking
amazing
um
so
but that's not that's not me that's
literally you that's all you guys right
and of course I curate them but I I'm
very detailed with what render is played
at what point in the music that I talk
with the artists then we go back and
forth on how to craft the music to best
fit the story so there is direction of
course but
yeah those things are sick
in terms of imposter syndrome on on
short films I definitely get that yeah
absolutely
um
I see the need to do better always and
uh that could be pretty debilitating a
lot of the times
uh could be a lot of pressure I do put a
lot of pressure on myself to do better
but I'm inspired by a lot of other
artists too that do such a great job
and uh
I'm like man
what am I doing like with with my as I
look at my like Instagram posts or
something and I'm like man these can be
so much Slicker and like way cooler and
even the announcement video I dropped
I'm I'm like oh man I could I could
spice this up so much more
but I just don't have time
and honestly
I don't need to I would rather put my
creative effort
I don't know
to a movie or
another short film I don't need to be
tweaking
the text and the font
and getting in the perfect spot but I do
that I do do that ah
I was just explaining
to my wife yesterday
that no matter how much I have on my
plate
I have to do my very best job at every
step of the way like
I can't short there's no way I cannot
shortcut it I can't be like
I'm just gonna do a halfway job on like
the stickers like no no I got to do the
full Max best job on everything along
the way and that takes so much time and
that's why I was up so darn late
last night trying to get this whole
thing launched
so yeah I I think I kind of took that
question a little bit off but I don't
know I hope
I'm sure a lot of you guys feel similar
a lot of perfectionists here in the chat
if you're a perfectionist
give me a thumbs up in the chat I want
to know
I know I know you're out there I know
you're out there
ah Tobias I I see what you mean you said
you feel like the amount of positive
feedback versus negative feedback you
get on your work on social media impacts
with how happy you are with the result
yeah like if everyone was like dude this
vehicle challenge sucks
the like the stickers that you put out
suck I would be like oh
oh
I was so excited about them
but now that everyone thinks it sucks
they're probably right it sucks oh no
like there's I I get that I get that for
sure
um
but no I think this this challenge is
gonna be sick uh
you know some people are like I don't
like the angle that's okay that's okay
you can't please everybody
can't please everybody yo perfectionist
in the house
I'm seeing them thumbs what's going on
foreign
what's up man
I didn't see you there
good to have you
do you think it's possible to become a
CGI supervisor in feature films and
succeed
probably like
you know what's you know what's scary to
think
Anything is Possible you can do if
you're dead set enough about something
you can do it
you can go any direction you want to go
and I know that a lot of us
may have different limitations
or environmental limitations on where we
can go but that's just an obstacle for
you to push through so
yeah I don't know
um
I truly believe that that we can do what
we put our minds through it sounds
cliche but I really do believe that
yeah man go for that dream job
why not
life is too short not to
ah Tobias okay but not getting any
feedback makes you feel uh judge the end
result I I get the same thing man I get
the same thing I'll I'll uh
I'll give you a little bit of personal
info so I posted a um let me show you
actually let me show you
so these guys I don't know how loud this
is gonna be I don't know
[Music]
I don't know if you can hear that
actually maybe I have to talk a little
bit for you to hear it
yeah it's like a little uh
Mega Man
it's called a pocket operator right so I
use this and you can have all these
different these different sounds
let me turn up the volume on this
[Music]
right and then you can change like the
tone and then it's got It's got Bass
all these bass tones and stuff it's a
it's a little portable synthesizer it's
super cool
you can change the sound
give it some Reverb
[Music]
and then you can sequence stuff together
too
oh I was jamming on this the other day
this I'm getting I'm getting to the
point I'm getting to the point
then we got like
[Music]
so you connect this
to this these go together and then you
start adding Reverb to it you start
adding delay to it you start like
you know adding different modulation and
tweaking the sound and oh my God I'll
get lost so I like I just got sucked in
I made this track and it was so sick and
uh and I posted it to Instagram and then
like no one commented on it I was like
man and I was like oh I must suck then
but no no I I have a blast that's the
point is I'm having a good time with it
but yeah of course I I would want more
people to be like oh that's so sick
but it's okay I I get you I feel you
yeah pocket operators man
they're so much fun here I'll show you
the other one
yeah they're by this company teenage
engineering they're called pocket
operators there's like a bunch of
different ones
um obviously I'm not sponsored or
anything by these guys but they're the
sickest things ever this one can record
anything so I could be like let's see
I don't want to overwrite anything I did
before
so I'll record
yo yo yo
then you can
play that back
and then you can filter it
and stuff
you could speed it up slow it down
right but then you take that and you go
to the piano
and then you get something like
[Music]
you know and then you can add a beat you
could sing with a sequence a beat to it
all I think I got something going here
you know
[Music]
and that's just recording the piano like
oh my God there's just this just this is
crazy it's so powerful
ah I love it
I love it
so much fun
you got a KO man the KO is the best one
ah yeah dude yeah it's a it's a it's a
sequencer right so you can like sequence
a Beat
all right it has these it has like 16
different uh little like uh steps for
you to sequence on and then you hit play
Let's see
right and you can see it going down
and then you got like effects and stuff
so sick
[Music]
yeah so that's pretty much when I'm not
doing video stuff that's what I'm doing
um I got this set up that I wanna like
have this portable set up go to the park
and just make ambient music
yes that is the best day ever
um yeah teenage engineering is legit
I'm getting a little derailed but I love
it I freaking love it
we have a few more minutes
um probably another 20 minutes and I'll
call it
because we got kickball today and we got
a barbecue after that so I'm gonna be
chilling it was a tough week
but we launched the the endless engine
engines challenge I'm really happy with
it
[Music]
um
I think this one's gonna be really cool
it's gonna be very unique I'm really
excited to see what you guys do with
these prompts
um what kind of vehicles you make
um and
you know I'm gonna be with you guys
along the way the only difference
this time around is I'm not streaming
every weekend I I need I need to take
some time to myself it's a little bit
much for me to stream every single
weekend during these challenges because
there's just so much excuse me there's
so much effort and so much work that
goes into it even outside of those
streams
so I'm gonna be doing a mid midweek uh
mid-challenge update video on the 18th
two weeks from now and then I'm gonna do
a one live stream after this so I'm
basically doing this kickoff live stream
and then I'm gonna do a live stream a
week before the deadline
um to help you guys
you know submit bring everything to
completion pretty much do FAQ but on
submitting and
and all that stuff and then of course we
have the the uh the judging stream where
myself Ren Peter and Captain dissolution
are going to get together and we're
gonna look at the top 100 and announce
the five winners of course that will be
on
what is it
12th Maybe
maybe I'm getting that wrong I have my
whole schedule in the announcement video
for you guys
oh thank you Soto we got it on screen
for y'all
um so yeah you guys can see right here
add it to your calendars all right um
you know I don't want you guys to miss
anything we got a lot of cool stuff
going on I want to be there to help you
guys out
um every single
Monday every Monday we're actually
getting together on the Discord side of
things and we're gonna do like an
hour-long Town Hall thing where we have
people come up talk about their idea
problems they're having
everyone gets like five minutes and we
move on to the next person so hop in
with that you can show off kind of where
you're at things your things that you're
struggling with things you're excited
about it's all fair game that'll be
every Monday on the Discord so just
another reason to hop in on the Discord
of course
um
and Soto do you have the
sticker video loaded up by chance or no
on the stream deck
no I don't
can you drop it in or I can you don't
know screw that I'm gonna just play it I
I have um I'll just play the video I
have it right here
let's see uh
[Music]
the stickers too so the first it's the
first time we're doing
like collectible merch for this
challenge
um I'm really really happy with how they
turned out my buddy Gabe
uh design the logo I'm pretty sure he's
the guy who designed the corridor logo
um but let's let's take a look here real
quick
so it's a whole sticker sheet right 12
uh 12 stickers different logos different
colors different sizes
um and it's on my print store I don't
know if you guys know but I do sell
prints of my art uh it's called
noisegrainandlight.com I've got a link
for you in the description
um and yeah I mean the prints themselves
are super high quality
um prints here that I have done
I have a special like printer she she
does a great job super high quality I
write you guys music recommendations on
the back
um along with the signature and a little
note
um but then this is the first time we've
done stickers so I'm really excited to
see how these come out this of course is
a render
um I put in an order for myself so I
can't wait to get them get them on hand
here but yeah we got a thousand of them
and once we sell out the thousand and
that's it but uh
it has this a full sticker sheet kind of
what it looks like
check this out though check this out
check this out
look at the background
it's all the little vehicles and stuff
a little motorcycle
cars sports cars and stuff just a nice
little touch
but yeah
um
yeah I'm excited to block out my scene
I think I'm gonna do a little camper van
situation off-road something
it'll be a good time very good time
all right now's the time y'all
uh
uh I'm gonna answer any other questions
you guys have save the polar bears I see
you
what's up won't apologize in advance for
how I'm gonna absolutely steal first
place oh my God
that's a lot of talk
son that's a lot of talk
can't wait to see how this challenge
feels for everyone I agree I absolutely
agree dude watch you sweep the
competition just call in your shots like
Tiger Woods straight just freaking
holding one calling it
the nerve but if you pull it off
everyone's jaw will be on the floor no
doubt but then if I pick you to win then
like
[Music]
then they're gonna be like yo it's
rigged
freaking challenge politics
um all right y'all hit me up with that
at Punisher and I'll answer as many
questions as I can in the last 15
minutes here
but I really wish you guys the best of
luck on this I can't wait to see this
all come together
um is there
equal judging on the vehicle versus the
environment or is it more focused on the
vehicle I'm assuming
um Jackson Davis good question no it's
overall it's overall feeling right it's
if your vehicle looks sick but your
background is but
then no you're not gonna
you know like that that it's it's an
overall thing it's a one-time it's a
glance
and does it look sick or not does it
feel well rendered does it feel
intentional
you know that's what I'm going for
overall Vibe not just the vehicle
good question though good question
how am I going to judge the renders
Paris all right
good question good question so here's
how I do it once we got get all of your
renders in on March 12th 11 59 PM PST
that is Sunday night my time okay I'm
gonna wake up on Monday
um on Sunday or sorry Monday the 13th
I'm gonna wake up I'm gonna download the
thousands of submissions I'm gonna get
them up into DaVinci and I'm essentially
going to filter them by frame rate
resolution
and uh frame count all right those are
the three things
all the all the renders that fit the
technical requirements for submission
get put into the good to go folder all
the ones that don't whether you're off
by a frame
etc etc
they go into the darkness folder you
don't want to be in the darkness folder
okay
and I'm going to get into that when I
when I put out the like the mid
challenge update video I'm going to show
you exactly what I'm looking at in
DaVinci so that you can check it
yourself DaVinci is free you can
we'll make sure everyone gets in the
good to go folder we don't want nobody
in that Darkness folder okay
I'll take all the good to goes
I'ma drop them up into the timeline
and then at the end of the timeline I'll
drop the darkness renders
and then I'm gonna go through every
single one I'll still look at the
darkness
unless it's too dark unless it's so dark
I can't see anything but if it's
darkness by like a frame off there's
only so many renders I can fix that are
a frame off before
I give up
so don't be in the darkness folder
submit properly I could be evil and just
say you're a frame off
freaking
dq'd done for
um but I try and make the top 100 as
awesome as possible the only thing we
don't stand for is late renders
late renders so sorry
so I look at all these renders okay and
then basically
I'm I go through each one pretty quickly
I'm not like flying through it I give
everyone a solid look and the moderators
are also you know we're in like mod chat
and we're all looking at them and
um someone might be like whoa whoa go
back go back
and we'll be like yo you're right it
should go up
but basically I go through and I give
each one about
about half the render
I that especially with this one because
I kind of want to see how the vehicle
looks and stuff
and I can tell pretty much immediately
if it's well rendered well lit
well-composed pretty pretty much
immediately
um
and then if it looks great I'll move it
up in the timeline and essentially I'll
pull the best 125.
and then I'll go through the top 125 and
with the moderators we'll scrunch that
down to top 100
then I go through and I pull my favorite
slash the best in my mind
subjective right but I think I do a
decent job
top 15.
I bring those top 15
um to Ren to Peter to Captain
dissolution and we'll we'll get together
and we'll pull our top five and then put
them in order that's how judging goes
down
so I always want to keep it open to as
many people that I trust as possible I
don't want it to just be on me
um because some people will really feel
that this render needs to be in versus
not like we should lose that one
um so it's like a back and forth back
and forth it's not just one person doing
it
but what am I judging what am I looking
for first off I'm looking for like
render quality is it rendered well does
it is it lit well is it composed well
are the colors nice is the anim is it
animated nicely
like all of that stuff is on a sliding
scale and you kind of kind of get the
vibe you know we I've been doing this
for almost three years at this point
looking at these challenge uh
submissions so I can tell pretty darn
quickly
but it's when we get into like deciding
first place second place third place we
take that Eagle Eye and we're really
looking at the details here
um
still animation lighting composition
color idea how creative was your idea
how unique was your idea did you follow
the the prompt
well enough or did you break too too far
off from it and it's like
I wish we could keep this one but it
just breaks the prompt too much
um
so that's kind of what I'm looking at
when it comes to uh when it comes to all
this stuff
let's see any more questions I see a few
of them
[Music]
foreign
Casey Edwards himself up in the chat
what up son
how you doing
that's Kim she says hello
I'm excited for that barbecue later
it's gonna be good that spicy Mac dude I
heard about that spicy Mac I'm ready I'm
ready son freaking we're ready
um
[Music]
any other questions
all right
mate maybe is how you say the name
having participated last time I saw a
lot of technical beautiful renders in a
lot
also a lot of creative ideas but less in
visual quality what's your tip on that
where to lean for new people
so you're saying like
one render might look beautiful
versus like an idea that was awesome but
it just wasn't executed as well as it
can
I think
first things first is like how good does
it look
how good does it look
because that is the thing that
draws everyone's attention is how nice
does it look how well is it lit how well
is it composed how well is it rendered
how well is it animated
does it look like a Pixar movie or does
it look like
an AI generated thing you know it's like
there's going to be a big difference in
the quality right
so that's number one it's like
how great does it look
um and then when I have when I have all
the renders that look great and then the
ones that have
great Concepts those stand above the one
that's that's next level right so it's
like you have all the ones that look
awesome but then there are going to be
some that look awesome and
have incredible Concepts those those are
even better right but if you have a
poorly executed incredible concept
then I would rather go with the one that
looks just amazing and is well composed
well lit versus an idea if you just have
the idea it's it's it's a bunch of
little things that come together right
so you want to kind of
keep all those things in mind
foreign
do we do we accept everybody in the 3D
Challenge from beginners to working 3D
animators can we all apply yes it's open
to everybody
it is open to everybody
um that is the whole point
I want to try and Inspire as many people
as possible to participate in this thing
we're all
like on different Playing Fields right
but
all of us are learning
so what might be easy for someone might
be difficult for another and if that
person which that technique is difficult
for learns that technique that's a
freaking win but for the other person
who maybe that technique is easy maybe
they have a technique that's super hard
for them maybe something that you might
be good at
you know so we're all we're all learning
it's all sliding scale
so that's why I just think it's
important to to recognize that
no matter how great you are we're all
we're all still learning at this and
we're doing it together with these
challenges that's the whole point we're
doing it together
crafter I can't I can't decide that for
you stylistic or realistic
can't make that decision for you brother
that is on you
Edge oh Edge dude I can't wait
see what you do with this you just want
to say that y'all kicked out of the park
with this one this is going to be the
best one yet that's what's up dude that
makes me happy
as well as the moderators too man we we
definitely put put a lot of thought into
this so
super cool
oh an audience poll
you know that's not a bad idea doing an
odd like leaving one of the slots open
to an audience vote that's not a bad
idea
hmm
I'll keep that in mind that's like
that's a that's a legit suggestion
Max is something like a spider-verse
look where the characters are 12 FPS
allowed if the overall is 24. yeah
totally totally totally I think that's
super cool yeah man
uh fader
fader not sure how to pronounce that but
uh
yeah man it's open to any vehicle any
vehicle
can you add wheel rotation or Direction
turns and what about drifts yeah I think
all that stuff is pretty pretty okay as
long again as you keep the sense of
speed and direction and leave your car
generally Center framed but again like
you guys can you guys can answer your
own questions here when you read the
rules you read the FAQs I do understand
it's a little bit scary you're like I
definitely want to if I'm gonna spend
five weeks on this I want to make sure
it's valid
um but have a little bit of faith in
yourself
just know if you can justify it in these
rules in the FAQs then you're good okay
you'll be all right you guys you guys
will be okay
um and I think with that guys I think
it's time to bounce
thank you guys thank you so much if you
hadn't watched the announcement video
definitely do that I uploaded it about
two hours three hours ago at this point
hop into the Discord server it's the
home base for this whole challenge for
all of our challenges
so um hop in for the challenge stay for
the weekly challenges and really stay
around for the community and of course
the future challenges
um what else what else
um
yeah I've mentioned it a bunch of times
at this point but y'all we got the
collectible stickers
um popping off on my print store
noisegreen and light.com in the
description
uh what else what else
definitely hit that green check box on
the Discord you guys will be getting all
the the updates the announcements I'll
see you on Monday we're gonna do that
little town hall in Discord we're gonna
go through your ideas
um bring people up to chat and stuff
so many people have clicked the check
mark have read the rules and downloaded
the files hopefully
you said yes oh shoot
uh
[Music]
uh ah I would say
not a bad guess not about yes it's 850
people already
shoot that's great
hold on let me check
let me check how many people downloaded
the link
jeez
2300 people
have clicked on the link download file
wow that's crazy yeah
wow that's pretty sweet
uh thanks everyone yeah and we got 786
people who clicked on the uh the Discord
link so
that's pretty great yeah that's like
literally everyone here in this live
stream
um and like everyone who clicked the
green check box so those are some good
numbers thank you guys I appreciate that
um good luck to you guys seriously we'll
see you on Discord
um
and I'll hit you guys in two weeks with
that with a little mid challenge update
every Monday we'll be on the Discord do
a little town hall I think I have
said everything I need to say so to
Monta you got anything before we leave
good luck just good luck
good luck guys have fun
peace out y'all
[Music]
thank you